europa lucha contra el calor extremo al
suroeste de francia en la región de ye
gon batalla nuevamente contra el fuego
unas 10.000 personas tuvieron que buscar
refugio mientras las llamas han
consumido cerca de 8000 hectáreas
bomberos de diferentes partes del
continente llegaron al rescate
y sentimos compasión por los franceses
que están expuestos a los incendios y
estamos aquí para ayudarlos y a nuestros
colegas en los cuerpos de bomberos
franceses
es como una bocanada de aire fresco
porque nuestros bomberos están cansados
después de un mes de lucha es realmente
un buen apoyo para nosotros para
trabajar en el incendio forestal por lo
que también podemos concentrarnos en las
otras operaciones que todavía están en
la gironda
en portugal un incendio lleva siete días
ardiendo y ha consumido 15.000 hectáreas
los lugareños también han tenido que
huir
tuve que evacuar a mis padres al pueblo
y vine a cuidar la casa mil 600 bomberos
luchar para contener las llamas que han
devorado el 15 por ciento del parque
nacional de la sierra de estrela en
reinounido el calor extremo llevó al
gobierno a declarar el estado de sequía
en ciertas zonas de inglaterra el
manantial natural que abastece al río
támesis ha presentado disminuciones
inusuales hechas parece muy diferente
este año está más seco mucho más seco de
lo que ha estado antes y la fuente se ha
movido unos cuantos kilómetros más allá
de lo normal en este país las empresas
suministradoras de agua potable pueden
comenzar a imponer restricciones para
proteger las reservas que por ahora no
están afectadas el calor extremo
provocado en gran medida por el cambio
climático podría empeorar ocasionando
que aumenten las sequías y por
consiguiente los incendios forestales en
un 30% en los próximos 28 años según
datos de la onu